mass testing in liverpool was popular
and effective hundreds of people were
found to have the virus
even though they had no symptoms and
case rates have fallen by three quarters
the strategy is now being rolled out to
other hot spots with the health
secretary suggesting it's the way out of
the new tougher tier three restrictions
that start after lockdown ends the light
of dawn
is on the horizon it's the moment to
stand firm until the morning
so we can look back and see clearly that
everything we gave and everything we did
it was not for nothing
but so we could save lives and build
back better
for everyone testing of two million
university students has also started to
reduce the risk of them
taking the virus home to vulnerable
relatives at christmas
josephine has been in manchester until
recently one of the worst affected areas
in england
i might be able to like like stand like
two meters away from my grandpa and like
say hi like but whereas if
if i don't take the test then that would
like make me much more like on edge
because i don't want him
like i don't want to make my
grandparents ill lock down has slowed
the spread of the virus with infection
rates falling by a third and even more
in areas of the north that were in tier
three researchers at imperial college
found that across england
72 000 people a day were being infected
in mid-november down from 100
000 a day at the end of october the
national
infection rate was about one in 100
people
but there were big variations around the
country with a hot spot
shifting from the north of england to
the west midlands where one in 64 people
were infected
all now hangs on the new stricter
tiering system
if the new tiering works we will avoid
any future any future lockdowns and and
if you know
and if it and if it doesn't work for
whatever reason um
then a new a third wave and
possibly an additional lockdown becomes
more likely but while infection rates in
adults are falling the study shows
they're still rising in children
schools have stayed open during lockdown
and term ends less than a week before
people are allowed to gather for
christmas we really can't deny now that
that
school-aged children um you know do get
infected for a while we hope that they
might not be as susceptible but that's
certainly not true especially for
secondary age
school kids um so we do need to
acknowledge that
that's a vector that can bring the virus
into our homes
and we need to be all the more careful
especially as we might be close to the
finish line with a vaccine on the
horizon
the vaccines are coming but it'll be
well into next year before they make a
difference until then
testing and tough restrictions however
unwelcome
are likely to be the best bet for
holding the virus in check
thomas more sky news